hi everyone um this is me age 12 uh
playing Space Invaders on my father's
apple
Toc um this probably one of the first
video games I I played actively and um
and it just just go to show that it
doesn't take that much to have a
compelling game if a machine with 128
kilobytes and a few black and green
pixels can can sort of do
it and nowadays uh you're more likely to
find a scene like this in our living
room so there's me reading my Kindle and
um my husband is uh playing um playing
games on his uh Playstation the nice
thing is that uh he's an avid gamer and
uh he likes to play highly rated and uh
unusual and creative games and so that
sort of gives me an Insight in uh in how
how interesting and Innovative the
medium of games can be
and uh this made me want to uh myself uh
start you know working on my own game
and uh since I've been working in higho
for more than the last year uh I decided
to uh do this project in
huso um which would allow me to push my
skills in a in a fun way uh so that's
what I
did actually there was a sound there
don't know
that's okay have mind so um the first
thing when you start a game is uh you
need a concept uh obviously the search
space is infinite uh everything is
possible your imagination is the limit
uh um and in this context I really like
uh this Twitter account which randomly
generates uh Games ideas and which which
turns out to be really amusing um
so um obviously uh you don't need to uh
to um Define your Concepts to the to a
very great detail because you can still
tweak it uh as you go
along
um um but once you've got your Concepts
you still have a number of choices
obviously what is the format you're
going to use uh you could do a text
based game like the BBC uh with The
Hitchhikers Guide to the Galaxy
perfectly nice format or you could go
graphical but if you go graphical you
can have different flows of your game
you can have a turn based like
Civilization or uh you could have a a
realtime game and if you have a realtime
game are you going to go 3D or are you
going to go 2D obviously
um uh your choices are limited by uh
your available time and skills so uh
making a 3D Adventure game as a oneman
team uh would be a tad ambitious
um but once you've got 2D you still have
the choice of your perspective you can
have a profile platform game or you can
have a top down game like this uh this
is actually the format I went for for my
game uh my game is um is uh is actually
based on the fact that our society is
obsessed with extinction level events
and I wanted to make a more hopeful game
with a little alien that goes around
that world and resurrects them one at a
time uh the first technical thing to get
going more or less is Graphics uh I
chose open G why open G well it's very
portable it's open
source um it's very powerful it's
actually completely overkill for 2D but
if I want to do a 3D game later then
I'll have the basics so I went with open
G uh and the bindings the hle bindings
are actually pretty transparent so this
means that if you find a C++ example
online it's actually relatively easy to
uh transcribe it uh to
hco there's other possibilities like
sdl2 or QT uh for 2D
games uh another Library which is really
useful is glfw it's a C library which uh
will function as um a a portable layer
between uh your open GL and the
operating system uh it will for instance
create Windows and uh handle inputs uh
from various
devices and uh with a fairly easy
utility function you can uh which you
can find online you can create a window
uh just like
this uh in a GL uh itself also um simple
uh openg G um initialization and the
interesting line here I I think is the
last line uh because we're doing a 2d
game we want an orthogonal perspective
that is we're looking down on our xwi
plane if you were doing a full 3D game
you would handle uh perspectives with
different angles uh which is more
complex uh so with this with a very
simple a fairly limited amount of code
you have a window going which doesn't do
much yet uh because to do anything you
need the loop so uh in any sort of
realtime system uh you have uh basically
a loop um the pseudo code goes like this
pole input events uh reacts to input and
change State render State and if you
don't exit loop again nothing new
there obviously there's no life without
State even if you have a little a little
character wandering around you still
need to keep track of their XY
coordinate to be able to render where
they
are uh a a fairly simple sort of first
deegree uh implementation of this Loop
uh would go like this so uh loop uh poly
vents uh gets the input Direction and
then uh with this function update the
state to a new state which you then
render I have this code online I'll give
you the GitHub link later and with this
simple thing you have something that
will react to keyboard inputs which is
already slightly more interesting than
the black window
before um there's one bit that doesn't
really fit in the pseudo code I was uh
showing before which is this uh does
anyone know why I use this waiting
function so your CPU CPU would get ar ar
rust yeah exactly so the answer was so
your CPU would get AR rest and that's
true because uh if you were going full
throttle and looping as as fast as you
could uh your graphical sort of
rendering and pipeline would get clogged
up uh because the render frame here must
have time to execute and anyway uh we
only need about 60 frames per second to
have uh something that is relatively
fluid in our game so uh it's no problem
to add a little bit of delay in this
Loop uh obviously um when I was looking
around uh through several examples of
existing games
um I found that a lot of people were
using functional reactive programming
which I did as well because I found it
an interesting Paradigm and it's
everyone is doing it obviously
uh so um the difference between FR FRP
and handling your state the usual way as
other people have already said is that
instead of defining your state as a as a
as a like you know a state structure
variable you have signals or streams uh
over time uh uh so the position of your
player is a is a signal over time and uh
this very simple example we saw before
can be expressed like this your left key
single signal gets pulled at intervals
and your player position gets adjusted
accordingly uh for every every time the
key is actually
pressed I used um so this is the sorry
see this is the original Loop uh this is
the loop the same Loop but expressed
with Lera which is um a functional
reactive programming Library if you saw
um Evan's talk earlier on about F
functional reactive programming this is
actually one of the higher order uh
functional reactive programming uh
Frameworks um it has uh monadic signals
and montic Signal generators uh but but
to explain this code um you capture the
external input into a
signal which you can then use in uh in
this because here you define the
dependencies between your signal so you
define how how your game will basically
hang together and uh here the only
dependency is um you move the player so
from an initial state it will start to
move the player uh depending on the
direction key and the end end of this
graph is rendering rendering the frame
and since it's a monad you can use a
applicative if you're interested um and
then uh the loop itself is this it will
um join the the network we just defined
uh which will actually uh make it go a
step along signal route to the next
state of the
network and then uh and and then you can
sort of and and render the the and
render as as as was uh as was expressed
here uh very very friendly author Elia I
asked him a few questions along the way
was always very
nice uh this is this is the graph of my
game to give you an idea that already a
fairly simple game uh leads to already a
more complex loopy graph of um of
signals and I'm curious to see where it
goes when it gets even more more complex
um another thing that I had to actually
uh contact the author of this library
for because I didn't see how to do it
was uh FP and levels so you have these
signals which will exist from the
beginning of time to the end of time and
that actually not actually what you want
when you have levels because uh in your
you want some parts of the states to die
when your level finishes uh the world
you use in your level must stop to exist
and get garbage collected right um
and so thanks to him uh I got to see
that you can add an extra layer uh to
your FRP and have a signal generator for
the level so you generate um depending
on on your need of the level count and
uh and so you have a signal generator in
your signal
generator a little bit more
evolved um so that's sort of the
technical side of things mostly um
um with this you can make your game work
but it's not enough to make it uh come
to life to be pleasant to play for that
you need for instance textures with uh
textures uh in open G um uh you will
actually project images onto uh open gel
shapes open gel will allow you to draw
squares and uh you know circles and
polygons and whatever but you want a
spaceship or you want uh you know you
want a landscape or whatever and that
will be uh possible thanks to textures
uh you have text vertex coordinates
Define your shape texture coordinates
will Define the projection of that image
onto your shape um so if you want a
one-on-one projection of a rectangle
rectangular image onto a rectangle then
your texture coordinates will uh be uh
correspond I think my laser pointer is
that uh
um uh so 0 0 with one corner one Z with
one corner 0 one and one one uh with so
you you you connect the texture with
every corner uh if you want uh your
texture to only be in a part of your
shape then you will use a larger number
than one so that it only projects a
small bit uh if you want it's uh you
want only a part of your image to be on
your texture same thing you sort of use
smaller numbers to project uh this
texture uh so an interesting thing is
that I lost an amazing amount of time
because I was playing fast and lose with
number conversions never use on safe
cores and that's not only in games in
general never use on safe cores it cost
me literally weeks to to sort of figure
out that I had to uh use the right
number conversions everywhere so yeah
that was
bad uh so uh since I'm uh if this is a
one woman show um I think didn't have a
designer at hand and uh I bought uh um a
fairly cheap uh graphical tablet uh to
make my own drawings which was a lot of
fun and uh this is my little character
uh obviously it's a little bit Amateur
hour but U but uh um so I like I like
this little alien because it has a
spacit and you can't you can see the
gender it doesn't have a gender it
doesn't have a face and uh for cute
Factor it also has has a uh toddler
proportions uh which may or may not have
been inspired by my daughter here
so um so you obviously the sound is also
important um like I think some games are
actually made by the soundtrack you you
you dream of the soundtrack that's so
it's it's a really important U
element and uh I used open Al uh which
is not thread safe but but but still
works you can play background music uh
on one thread and and
fire uh sound events on the other thread
if you take some precautions and it sort
of
works um obviously uh now your Loop uh
has to express more than one thing you
need to render frame but you also need
to Output sounds depending and so uh you
add uh you make a more generalized
output
function uh
which uh which which uh sort of threads
those both um both outputs and then you
you use this um and your sound State
should only have the relevant
information for your
sound uh then we have um obviously you
also need animation some parts will will
be moving as you
go so I first went with um a really
naive implementation which is like my
little character needs to walk so I'm
going to make the legs move like this
and uh and I literally coded that in in
the code like it goes sinus and coinus
however if you want uh something more
evolved uh you can really keep on doing
this and for this you have uh what is
called key frame animations where you
have a few key frames uh which you uh
interpolate uh
between and if you're you have a a
really complex movement going on you go
for skeletal animations where you define
the skeleton for for your um your
character and uh and and rotate and
translate as it's needed so that's
that's a more even more complex level um
I was pointed to blender for um for uh
the key frame animations because blender
allows you to uh save object files
containing the ver vertices of um of
those key frames I was talking about uh
which makes it easier to then load them
and interpolate between them but blender
is actually not a very user friendly
tool so I'm still working on that plus
I've not seen any examples in hcll code
yet so I'm sort of making it up as I go
along but it's on the
program physics uh my game my particular
game doesn't require physics um but um
but if you have any anything that
bounces or Falls or jumps or whatever
you need uh physics you can brawl your
own uh if it's simple enough or you can
use ex existing libraries U there's a 2d
physics Library uh which uh which is
called chipmunk and it has highle
bindings called hipmunk and uh I have a
prototype on my GitHub account if you
want to have a look uh and it works so
um what you do with a physics Library
you um Define
your space with a gravity uh then you
Define physical bodies corresponding to
your graphical elements um so a physical
the physical body has mass friction
elasticity joints
Etc and then um and then you you step
your physical um your your physical
engine your physics engine uh as your
Loop progresses you step it uh through
in time as well and that gets you um um
a
result and what I found actually is it's
it's not that easy to combine this sort
of thing with uh the FRP so um but I
don't need it anyway so that wasn't a
problem so far uh my little game uh is
to the point where I feel most technical
Hur hurdles are are passed I can uh
start concentrating on making it
playable so um be be it is it is a it is
a the first game I made um so this is a
little
demo oh thank
you uh so my little character goes and
[Applause]
resurrects
so
um the Lessons Learned in this is um
well first let's talk about
hll uh so the nice things um types are a
really good way to express her domain
and the possible state so so that was a
lot of fun pattern matching great way to
um to represent your state machines uh
and all the transitions between the
various
and also I must say I was impressed with
the with the bindings with the native
libraries which which really mostly
worked so so that was handy um now uh
there are some unanswered questions
because I haven't finished the cycle
with this game which is a first game um
distribution uh how can I package this
uh porting how will this port to other
uh other platforms uh all the libraries
I used were supposed to be uh easy to
Port but uh a friend tried it on Linux
and had a second SE fold so it would
definitely need more
testing uh performance this is a small
game how will this work when you have 50
levels how will this work when you have
lots of
data
um then um obviously hll is a lazy
Language by default uh in a game you
don't you don't really want that so use
strict or eager data structures numbers
were
possible uh also getting things started
was horribly painful I went through like
literally 20 examples by various people
trying different libraries and those
libraries either didn't compile or or
they they they they SA faulted or they
they didn't work in some way and so it
took it took me a fairly long time to
narrow down to a tool set I could I
could actually work
with and then there's a compilation so
so uh I think the feedback loop uh when
you use such a compiled language is not
ideal because you change something you
compile you start again you change
something it's it's not it's not the
fastest Loop you can wish for I hear
that with C++ games people embed uh Lua
interpreter so they can directly
interact with states by with with a
script which allows you to test things
on the Fly and uh I wonder if this this
such a thing uh would be possible with
HK so if you're really smart and have
time on your hands that would be a good
thing to
do um so uh the second thing in my
lessons learned is that I think um the
the hard thing is not the technical side
the hard thing in the game is actually
making a really nice playable uh you
know attractive game I have already have
the feeling that it will take several
tries to get to a game anyone would want
want to play ever and um and uh I was
recommended this which is a deck of
cards uh which talks about several
aspects of the game so so for instance
imagination or fun or whatever and it
has several questions uh uh pushing you
to think about those aspects so I found
this a helpful thing but again I don't
think it's an easy easy thing whatever
tool you're
using uh other people have done this and
commercially this is the first uh
commercially um uh published hll game
called Nikki and the robots uh the
graphical framework they used was um QT
and uh the code is open source so you
can have a look and I did but it didn't
build on on my Mac
unfortunately uh thing uh there was a
lot of no uh this this made a lot of
noise recently uh it's a game Studio who
managed to to run a hll uh I guess
window sdl2 window uh in on mobile so
that means they can start developing
mobile games in h which is kind of
exciting and then um there's a wayward
Tides by the studio chucklefish they
they're hiring hll developers
interesting in interested in developing
games so there is definitely something
in the air about
this uh finally um this is work in
progress but uh I figured that uh since
it was such a such a terrible pain to
get started I could avoid this for other
people so they that they can they can
get onto the interesting problems of
making a game and so I'm publishing an
ebook on Lim poop uh if you're
interested so yep that's it thank you
for your
[Applause]
attention
thank you any
questions uh yes one did you uh work
with any other game developers uh in
your areas any kind of group like that
uh so the question was did you work with
any other game developers um not really
I guess I was in touch with um the
author of Elia as I said which who is a
game developer himself but but uh that's
sort of the extent of of my
contact I'm a remote worker so I don't
have a a huge group of people around
me uh yes what's your
jobob my day job uh I'm um consultant
and I do mostly
hosal
yeah yes um one of the things I found
difficult in just doing some hobby game
develop is the idea of testing my games
and making sure that I don't regress
bugs and things like that um and that's
that's causing interesting problems for
me have you come across that yet or you
still pretty early in the phe of build
uh pretty early but I also wondered
about that I have the feeling that um
that you can only test part of your game
successfully
like I don't see how you can test like
integration test again I have no idea
how to do
that so the game the question sorry the
question was how to test test your
game yes um you said that comp was know
comp and
then so the question was uh so the the
feedback look was a problem so did you
think of trying um the ghti repple um I
had a look at that so
um actually
uh people
people the things I found online
suggested that it was really difficult
to do that with open
G um so I haven't haven't really got it
working
myself did you do any Research into
component
systems so the the question was did you
do any research in entity comp component
systems for this uh no so I definitely
uh am aware that um there is definitely
a a whole in my in my knowledge and
there is a very interesting book called
uh game programming patterns I think
online which I definitely should check
out but I haven't haven't no at at this
level I haven't really done it no just
thought it would be interesting I don't
know how
you
so any other questions
yes
yeah
um so I think the problem is that um so
you're you're you're already dealing
with
one
um with one massive State machine which
is openg G and the physics is like
another massive State machine next to
that and I like I've tried with a very
simple example to make it work um and
for some reason like physical bodies got
garbage collected so I must have been
doing something wrong
um I find it really in difficult to
integrate it with with this like graph
structure and the state Evolution uh
because like I say you're working with
with this this big thing which is like a
Universe on its own and doesn't connect
with the other other state signals
you're
programming yes did you look at um any
or did you find any Frameworks for
building games in H or anything like
that um because that's something very
common in other Lang nonfunctional
environments to save the trouble of
having to implement your own Graphics
stack and your own physics stack and
glue all those p together uh so so the
question was are there any uh game
Frameworks in hcll that would spare you
all the trouble uh of of of of uh
building your own graphical stack Etc to
tell you the truth I found one um uh I
guess uh 2D game monut uh but it seems
fairly fairly limited um it didn't seem
to do that much and also again I didn't
get it to run that's a problem h seems
to evolve at a certain speed and if
people are not maintaining their their
libraries they they die so
yeah any other
questions does your daughter play your
game the question was does your daughter
play your game uh no she's at mashing
mashing keyboard stage so not really
working
yet so okay thank
you